[Music]
surfing for me is kind of a therapy it
brings a lot of joy and happiness
when creating one of our surfboards we
are making our own filament made from
locally collected plastic trash
this is how we can make the industry
sustainable and long-lasting
[Music]
my name is roman paul and i am the owner
of yuyu
i've been making surfboards for many
years now
the traditional way and we started this
business because
we experienced what we call the surface
paradox which is a major contradiction
between the eco-friendly mindset of most
surfers and the toxicity of the
equipment we use
regular surfboards the materials that
they're made of the polystyrene the
polyurethane the resins it's highly
pollutive they're not recyclable and all
of these materials are highly toxic and
we said this is not possible there must
be other ways to do this
we set up a new process which is based
on large format 3d printing and
bio-composite materials
when creating one of our surfboards it
all starts with the chat with the client
because each of our boards is made on
demand and based on on the surface needs
first we gather plastic trash from local
associations we work with
then we shrink it to make filament
and then we print the inner structure of
the board with a large format 3d printer
and then we laminate it with
bio-composite materials natural basil
fiber
combined with a plant-based bioresin
when the lamination is done we do the
paintings and the glassing and sanding
our surfboards do surf as well as a
regular surfboard it's even a little
better because you have this air inside
that acts like a floating carpet and it
enhances the experience
so we decided to adopt the 3d printing
technology because it enabled us
to use the materials we wanted in our
case recycled materials also to have a
local manufacturing process because it's
quite small so we can have everything
done at our workshop here in montpellier
in the south of france
and also we do not generate any other
waste we use only the strict amount of
materials that is necessary to make the
ball we don't cut anything and then we
realized that it also had tremendous
potentials in terms of ultra
personalization and also the search for
performance
being a small business owner is
difficult uh a challenge especially in
innovation because you have to be
convinced full convinced 200
in what you're doing and at the same
time be open to advice and new
technology and materials so we keep on
trying to improve what we do
i try to be an example for the industry
because small business is a choice for
us we think that uh we are heading
towards a new paradigm in industry with
micro production sites in different
parts of europe of uh in the world where
there is need for
recycling plastic and for
surfing
[Music]
for us it's our role as users of this
natural environment
to show that we can do things
differently and we can have more
sustainable and more responsible
behaviors
[Music]
you